all right you know what I'm gonna
[__] get all cholo Style with it my
mom was like you ain't wearing that [__]
my dad's like not let him because my dad
knew he's like I'm gonna let the
[__] learn [__] I'm in the
bathroom at school and these [__]
fools from another Hood come to me for
your process showing up my [__] and they
jump me you know and they slam my head
against the metal door did they and I
got 12 Staples in my head and and my you
know my mom told me not to worry so I go
home lying to her I'm like no we were
playing basketball and I have L on a
brick wall and ah dang you know and so I
made up these lives but but that's but
I'm glad that happened at a young age at
12 because I immediately switched back
to Bugle Boy jeans and cargo shorts
you know
I was trying to be something I wasn't
homie I'm a fighter homie I'm a lover
dog
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
[Music]